hey kim
hey becca so we've been talking about
uncle tom's cabin uh published in 1852
by harriet beecher stowe and said to
have been one of the main causes of the
american civil war so
remind me again what uncle tom's cabin
was actually about so uncle tom's cabin
was about the horrors of slavery in the
deep south and also appealed to a lot of
americans christian values and tried to
point out these fundamental
contradictions between christian faith
and slavery so it was published in 1852
how did people receive this book so
there was a lot of mixed reactions uh
but it was the most read book of the
19th century so there were a lot of
reactions
and so in the north mostly people were
reading this all the time no matter if
you were an intellectual or just kind of
a 17 year old picking up a book off a
shelf you were going to read uncle tom's
cabin and a lot of the people that
actually read the book were young men
that would later fight in the civil war
oh interesting okay so like this would
be our book club book of the month
except everybody was this was like the
oprah's book club choice of 1852
exactly everybody was reading it yeah
there's really almost nothing like it
like not even harry potter but it did
have the same international scope that
harry potter does today so it was
popular in the northern united states
and elsewhere in the world so where else
was it popular
mostly in europe um but it was
translated into over 60 languages
and
this also kind of put the spotlight on
american slavery so there was all this
international attention what what is
going on in america and what's gonna
happen so interesting it reminds me of
the king and i uh if you've seen that
she
the woman goes to siam and shows people
the um
the book uncle tom's cabin and they put
on a version of a play based on uncle
tom's cabin in what would be thailand so
yeah so this makes it this kind of
international spectacle the fate of
slavery had to be somehow figured out
and everyone was watching that's so
interesting so i'm imagining that white
southerners were not big fans of this
book so white southerners were
definitely not a fan of uncle tom's
cabin and in response there was this
movement of these things called anti-tom
novels so here's an anthony tom novel
right next to us
right over here aunt phyllis's cabin
so anthony says cabin yes
very creative name um these anti-tom
novels aim to point out that maybe harry
beecher stowe didn't know what she was
actually talking about they also accused
harriet beecher stowe of not actually
even living in the deep south so she
didn't even know what slavery was like
they wanted to paint southern slave
society in this really positive light
they wanted to show all the ways that it
actually maintained social order and
promoted economic welfare so this was
kind of this response from the south
also in novel form yeah so it's this big
kind of cultural battle over the
interpretation of slavery you have
people on one hand saying you know
slavery is destructive to families
slavery is incompatible with
christianity and then responses from the
white south saying oh no actually
slavery is great it helps everybody
right so there was this kind of battle
within the literary community about the
peculiar institution of slavery which
one was it so what if i'm illiterate
right i mean not everybody in 19th
century america was a new england
intellectual who was reading
christian novels how would i have heard
about uncle tom's cabin that's a really
good point kim so
tom's shows were depictions of uncle
tom's cabin in theaters around the world
and so they were often times put on by
abolitionist people trying to point out
the issues with slavery today and end
slavery immediately so this is before
there's copyright law right so you can
just put on a show of anybody's novel if
you feel like it exactly but oftentimes
they really misconstrued the novel and
actually now are remembered as
contributing to the problem of racism in
america racial stereotypes too i would
imagine because we still have this
phrase uncle tom kind of to mean
an african american who is a martyr
to the status quo as opposed to someone
who might fight against racism it seems
like they might have borrowed a lot of
these stereotypes from minstrel shows
which were also very popular in this
time period and some of the characters
within these minstrel shows turned into
the character that was remembered as jim
crow which became the dominating racial
order after the civil war so in the
civil rights era in the mid 1950s lots
of activists actually wanted to
completely reject the progress that
uncle tom's cabin and these tom shows
had made because they actually reduced
african americans to this terrible
stereotype and so
later on this kind of idea that someone
was an uncle tom became a racial slur
really and they then rejected uncle
tom's cabin as being a tool towards
racial equality and more saw it as part
of the problem so i think the most
important thing about uncle tom's cabin
is that it's this catalyst
of really intense emotions about slavery
which in the 1850s will lead eventually
to the civil war and you know following
the publication of uncle tom's cabin
you'll see more and more violence on
both sides of this issue for example
john brown this famous abolitionist
actually goes out to kansas and murders
people
and i think that lincoln was very astute
in pointing out that uncle tom's cabin
really catalyzed a lot of this violence
and he even met with harriet beecher
stowe so she earned herself a little
meeting with
abraham lincoln
and he said so you're the little lady
that started this great war
i'm trying to think of another book
that has started a war i think we would
probably
remember that but i do think lincoln was
really a student pointing out just how
impactful this cultural phenomenon this
tom mania was on the question of slavery
and on the fate of the american people
and really it just begged the question
in a new way in this kind of
public setting i mean i just think that
the book itself the way that the book
could just travel all around the united
states and so many different kinds of
people were able to read it and get
their hands on it this really was just
this movement of people just thinking a
lot about slavery reading a lot about
slavery yeah well i think you know after
uncle tom's cabin i don't think there
was a way to not have an opinion on the
slavery issue either you were for it or
you were against it and that
divisiveness would lead to the civil war
and again there's this international
focus there's a deeper sectional divide
between the north and the south and
there was this kind of sorting over the
slavery question that uncle tom's cabin
really promoted